on ouvre à présent une large page emploi
et formation le GRETA des Yvelines est
un organisme de formation continue
destiné aux adultes ces formations
permettent aux demandeurs d'emploi ou
aux salariés de s'insérer sur le marché
de l'emploi ou de se reconvertir et pour
plonger ou replonger ces personnes dans
le monde de l'entreprise le GRETA des
Yvelines a ouvert en 2016 une entreprise
école appelée également entreprise
d'entraînement pédagogique elle a pour
objectif de simuler le fonctionnement
d'une entreprise dans le secteur
tertiaire fauchek fausse alerte faux
bilan faux clients mais 67% des
bénéficiaires retournent vers l'emploi
grâce à ce dispositif pour en parler
avec nous Luc nouvelle vous êtes
conseillé en formation continue pour le
GRETA des Yvelines alors première
question est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter cette école cette entreprise
école alors effectivement l'école
d'entreprise pédagogique qui est née en
2016 dont je suis aussi le président
voilà puisque c'est une entreprise
virtuelle certes mais qui fonctionne
comme n'importe quel PME ou PMI donc
cette entreprise a pour vocation
effectivement d'être un tremplin qui
doit amener les bénéficiaires vers
l'emploi elle est née en 2016 mais en
fait c'est un concept qui est beaucoup
plus ancien c'est un concept qui vient
les États-Unis mais surtout qui a été
importé en Allemagne en 1980 et le
co-fondateur de cette idée était présent
ce matin monsieur trotton qui a
développé effectivement cette idée que
il était intéressant de mettre les gens
en formation professionnelle mais non
pas forcément de manière théorique mais
d'allier la théorie à une pratique
directe voilà donc a l'EP d'Achères vous
avez des plateaux techniques qu'on
appelle qui sont liés au service de
l'entreprise donc vous avez des
secrétaires vous avez des comptables
vous avez des ressources humaines et
vous avez effectivement aussi du
commerce voilà donc il y a combien de
personnes au total dans cette règle
générale il y en a au moins une
quarantaine qui font vivre le pays avec
une direction qui est liée aussi donc il
y a des coordonnatrices pédagogiques et
assistantes qui font vivre au quotidien
et qui mettent en action avec des
formateurs qui sont considérés comme des
chefs de service du coup les personnes
donc c'est des salariés si vous voulez
de l'EP mais qui reproduisent les mêmes
attentes par rapport aux besoins de
l'entreprise et donc parlons non non
ce dispositif selon vous et ben la
réussite en fait c'est que les personnes
se sentent accompagnés et il y a une
individualisation qui est faite au
quotidien donc ça veut dire qu'en fait
vous n'êtes pas jeté dans des méandres
quand vous êtes en difficulté quand vous
êtes salarié en reconversion ou quand
vous voulez devenir chef d'entreprise
voire demandeur d'emploi donc vous avez
un accompagnement vers la réussite en
fait qui permet avec des bilans
intermédiaires de solutionner en tout
cas d'apporter des plus aux personnes et
donc il y a combien
avec ce dispositif depuis 2016 vous avez
entre 100 et 130 personnes qui sortent
de l'EP et donc tout le monde peut y
accéder ou est-ce qu'il y a des critères
tout le monde peut y accéder vous
évidemment un positionnement lié au
projet de la personne après un sourcing
qui peut être de Pôle emploi ou
d'individus qui nous trouvent sur
Internet et vous avez aussi le handicap
qui est mis en avant puisque
effectivement comme on a une convention
avec la Gifi et bien on peut recevoir
des personnes dites handicapées
puisqu'on leur offre la possibilité de
se réinsérer en tout cas de voir sur nos
plateaux techniques qui sont accessibles
et on peut aussi les aider dans tout ce
qui est matériel adéquat avec leurs
problèmes pour pouvoir les intégrer
à l'entreprise alors comment on fait
pour pour accéder à cette formation
est-ce que c'est gratuit
les financements viennent soit de la
région soit de Pôle emploi soit du CPF
soit de la transition pro puisque
actuellement on en parle peu mais c'est
un moment important puisque tout salarié
peut effectivement bouger évoluer et
changer de métier grâce à ce dispositif
donc c'est financé en partie mais est-ce
qu'on doit mettre quand même un peu la
main à la poche alors on règle générale
actuellement non d'accord voilà même
avec la Gifi en fait vous avez des
personnes qui sont prises en charge et
donc vous proposez des formations dans
quel domaine dans quel secteur alors là
principalement à l'inverse du Greta de
manière générale qui propose 9 domaines
d'activité là le P est lié au tertiaire
principalement c'est pour ça que je vous
ai énuméré un petit peu les métiers qui
étaient dispensés voilà par les
formateurs et par le V et donc vous avez
eu la visite ce matin la fin du
directeur de la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de Versailles le président
le président monsieur Guillaume Kerrou
qui est venu nous rencontrer suite à une
rencontre sur un salon à Poissy et
il ne connaissait pas en fait l'outil
donc ça l'intéresse forcément puisqu'il
est lié à l'entreprise puisque lui il
aide les entrepreneurs et nous ça peut
nous intéresser de passer éventuellement
une convention qui pourrait avoir lieu
prochainement d'ailleurs sachant que on
pourrait répondre à des besoins précis à
déterminer bien sûr en termes de
pédagogie et de de
d'intérêt pour les les deux puisque
c'est du gagnant-gagnant sur le P
absolument voilà et bien merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation si vous
êtes intéressé par ce dispositif vous
trouverez davantage de renseignements
sur le site internet qui s'affiche juste
en dessous